hello and welcome to this video yeah I'm
going to make another tournament video
that was fun I'm a little bit late with
the join before we get there just a
quick word that the Black Friday sales
are getting to an end and there are just
two courses uh on sale for 48 hours left
the Dirty Harry Sicilian the fun
Sicilian opening um that I'm playing for
black maybe we get some the video and
the lifetime repertoire C4 KN F3 is back
on sale for 48 hours so make sure to get
it um as long as it's still possible all
right now let's get uh right into the
action if I would be yeah this is the
thing now um where is that Arena
tournament the
hourly what can we do here I can do the
blitz or the super Blitz super Blitz
will be very
fastpaced come on
um or what what are we going to
do I I think probably if we go for this
one I can
still berserk all the games and um still
being able to talk a little bit about my
thoughts is that a good setup I had some
problem with the
camera so let's see when the board is up
and I have to make this a little bit
smaller now we can do that or even a
little bit
more opponent is not
playing so maybe we get a Dirty Harry
under board give give me the open
no
okay okay this is a nice line for
black okay I don't want a double Pawn
it's not a big deal
but given the choice I'd rather not have
it on
C6 so I have berserked down to two and a
half
minutes but it's still plenty of time so
there's absolutely no need to uh panic
in a way this is now very nice because I
can simply take
here on F3 and even take again Bishop D4
I can take with the
Knight Bishop D4 Knight D4 Rook F3
Knight F3 for a big
fork and I also have Queen G4 them okay
um what now probably keep the Queens on
the board I don't need to trade just yet
it's very nice here okay if if you give
me an exchange I'm going to take
it you that looks very
nice King coming up to
C6 and then I'm going to expand on the
queen side with
B5
okay I really don't mind if they open up
the position for me that
uh can only be nice for the
Rooks covering C5 and simply
take the more open files the
better and
take yeah he's got he's got a knight C5
check but it's just one
check and then the D4 Pawn will become
terminally
weak no I got
this there's no way to keep that
pawn I don't think so at least so take
it and he's also falling apart here on
the fourth
ringer he can take that exchange but
going to win the rest of the pawns
there let's stop this it's probably not
a threat
but it's just
easier okay so I was a quick win and and
I have to catch up a little bit I'm
late but um if you get some three poins
in it's going to be really really fast
that I'm on the
leaderboard
so
okay oh wow 1,200
maybe I should have played
E4 that's not even part of my usual
repertoire but okay let's it it turned
out well yeah I have a nice
central control
already against H H
Kim Heim Hy
Kiran
yeah now he has to I mean E5 is a huge
threat probably I don't know maybe he
has to go E5 himself or something like
that very
difficult this is now looking um more or
less toast I can take on
H7 yeah this is a game
over game
over
check the queen will join or queen D3 if
he goes to G6 now Queen
H5 I'm
threatening far too much
here and made so it worked out with the
quick win even with the reti opening
mean reti is is good it's a good opening
but um in um context of the Arena format
where winning quickly is rewarded
playing a largely strategic opening is
uh sometimes um not the best
strategy playing in Gambit style can be
very
helpful now I'm not getting a game give
me a
game let's get some water here always
keep hydrated even in the in the
four in the summer it's important but in
the it's still even important in the
fall oh sorry hope that is not too
noisy okay that's
oops my I cannot cannot
coordinate
sorry
so I I was happy to
trade to get this dark
squid control now I've got three pieces
here three pieces
that are connected here with the dark
squares
and what is he doing here let me this is
a bit lame maybe but uh I'm slightly
afraid that he's going B Bishop H6 and
H4 and so on and uh this might not be
the way to a quick win but I'm taking
reliable here my position is comfortable
he cannot easily push E5 or D4 and I
have an easy plan like attack on the
queen
side okay so
A6 Knight D5 is
mostly just a threat uh just a check
just a threat Knight C7 I mean it's just
a check oh interesting didn't see that
coming not a bad move
actually oh maybe maybe it's actually a
bad
move this is a very annoying move to
face he doesn't really want to give up
that Bishop but he cannot move
it and uh that's a bit of a
pain yeah that's that's a bit of a pain
but okay if I take on E3 and he can
recapture with the pawn it's not it's
not a disaster but I'll be fine on the
dark squares so take this I wonder if he
has C6 that's just fantasy chess right
that doesn't work
no this is just nice I've got a very
nice
diagonal got Knight A4
coming Rook C8
potentially oh okay
that could
be dangerous for
white yeah but how exactly it's not
easy now this is actually not that great
he's got Rook C1 and is just about
holding
this yeah he's he defended this quite
well
so at least he has no good way to cover
A3 King A2 I just take on
B4 yeah so I'll
be up a bit of
material cover this Rook A1 would be
nice
to have this little trick that would oh
this is also
good speed speeds up the conversion
enormously
okay does it update
quickly so I'm I'm getting there yeah
there are a couple of people also won
all the games and uh doing it
quickly
helps portz balma is pretty strong as an
I am I think I have played him yeah four
times yeah in the in the
league I should maybe really play E4 but
okay I'd like to play my usual
repertoire this is uh also in
the livetime C4 Knight F3
course just a bit better for white
disposition how do we get where we want
to get let me check
it I'd like to have Knights on D3 and
F3 this is a bit
slow but
probably still okay is he going Knight
G5 there or I don't
know he's going for this
uh very uh
direct
attack
okay so F4 or is that running into some
kind of tech uh attack I don't know no
Knight G3 doesn't
work not certain maybe this one I would
like to keep a knight
and what's going on uh let's go
C5 I'm still okay
TimeWise
yeah he's playing this actually quite
well this is a good
one getting to
H5 I'm not
sure this is a somewhat risky
decision on my end I mean taking but I
think he doesn't have a his attack here
is not so serious actually G4 no not yet
I can first do
this it's difficult to imagine um that
he can Checkmate me
here even after G5 I can still simply
let him take and take with a
rook um
okay
so
that's bit annoying this one double
up go there a queen trade obviously
would be brilliant I would be just
winning after Queen
trade This Is My Idea Queen to E2
maybe then he has to trade or
Retreat yeah now this is very good no
now there's no
attack and um he he
cannot defend the queen side
yeah the Knight on E5 is is of course is
crushing but I was a little bit
concerned some moves ago that really
didn't look so clear to
me got too much on the seventh
rank
yeah that's
it h that's a little bit pointless
really
okay okay the fourth
win and portz balma did not berserk the
the last game I think given the
opposition in this tournament it's
probably the correct strategy to berserk
all of them
I don't
know I usually do best if I absolutely
commit to berserk every game because
then I have this flow in a way I'm not
brilliant at this the the the super fast
time controls but at least once I'm I'm
in this mode I I
can yeah um I can stay in this in this
Rhythm but if I switch back and forth it
sometimes gets problematic for me
yeah got the pretty slow English opening
or what is he doing here let's go
E5 oh okay so we get a king's Indian
attack
formation oh just shutting everything
down but this is pretty nice for black
I'm just
faster with the F Pawn
break it's often a key
a key point in those binic
structures okay let's keep this
covered it's still not so bad for white
so let's push
this if he allows G5
uh I don't know but okay what what what
exactly is he supposed to
do maybe some counter attack here I
don't know it's C4 E5 but now I'm just
threatening G4 already this is not
fun it's got the check on
C3 yeah I mean if I get to F3 his Bishop
is completely buried that looks uh
pretty
awful yeah he's got no square right 92
may be relatively best but it's not
fun n it doesn't look
good where do you go now where do you go
that's why kind
of nobody
knows okay so
F3 I think that that should be played
them just
uh putting this
bishop completely oh he just sacrifices
interesting okay so let's take I could
take here
actually it looks like a good
solution it's a Tempo and the queen
that's um
important oh
okay just just take
this you don't need to make it more
difficult than strictly necessary he's
got D4
check and he had this check on B7
actually that
uh yeah that was somewhat dangerous
actually that's something that I should
have uh should have paid more attention
to
and my king position is
still a bit
open yeah I can simply take here right
or take with the Rook does he have a
check
no no but I got a
million of discovered checks and they
are pretty
strong yeah I was shaky a little B had
the check on B7 that would have been a
scary moment but I always have Queen D4
I think I think it was
winning
okay so the anti slav here black has a
white choice of moves and actually even
against those like Bishop G4
is slightly
dubious um even against that white has
a variety of good
options yeah here also you can take the
taking is is a simple and good option
where white just is
better nothing too dramatic but I mean I
just have the bishop PA for absolutely
nothing um yeah King E2 is
possible can I play Knight D5 here this
is one of those
funky moments Knight D5 Knight D5 cd5
Bishop D2 G
E6 huh that works
sometimes yeah I'm not
sure going for
the for the simpler option of shutting
down the position oh he takes it wow
okay does he have F6 E5
coming yeah I mean he can play it
but the resulting structure should be
fairly
nice okay it doesn't
care che che che
che huh I'm not quite sure about
it I think this
first
and take once
here
um this is it's not as good as I thought
I thought this would be even better but
it's
not it's not uh extremely bad for
him love to play D5 here but it doesn't
work now D5 is a
completely it's a huge
threat yeah it's not it's not as great
really it's not as
great oh knight4
o ah
ouch why is he thinking about
it it's just
strong still strong it was Stronger
before even Knight
E4 maybe I'm getting away with Rook B7
and
doubling okay no doesn't do
it not sure why
not to go
back some some surprising choices I
thought he was
had much better
options unless I'm just getting M but
I'm not
M this one there this
one go back
Tempo not sure if this was good
actually C7 doesn't work should have
played this one
before quite
[Music]
Stupid King E2 and then
taking 36 seconds is a little
bit little bit of an
issue
still has to
be
converted not
ideal Knight G4 now is very annoying
doesn't do
it h
three h
I'm getting there I think I'm getting
there
yeah I'm just promoting this
basically Knight G3 is not even a
move
Dam that was a bit OD what did I do
there there was I probably played the
wrong after E5 that was a wrong way to
to change the
structure
interesting so as mentioned I'm I'm
berserking because of like I want to
keep this Rhythm that I'm in it's not a
disrespect thing or
anything I even berserked against much
higher uh rated
opponents in those
tournaments because my experience is
like if I don't do it it I I I tend to
be uh off time
wise my time management is a an
issue do I want to take that's the
tricky one I think I
want the particular setup looks good
because he cannot avoid
this that he has to take with the
pawn in some cases this is not so fatal
because black gets to open up the
position um quickly
enough that could be such a case some F5
for
example I I don't mind a further tra
this is the F5 that I me that I that I
mentioned but I can
still try to claim an advantage
here the check and he was going to take
there yeah
probably can take D6 I also have the
move F6 which is a little
bit
strange but maybe interesting that
something where having more time would
be good but
well you cannot have it all
obviously so um Rook F6 that's not great
actually he has a Tempo yeah he has a
Tempo if he takes
it I mean not a Tempo sorry that's the
wrong way to say it but I have to worry
about the F3 Pawn that's what I I tried
to
say n it was badly played now I'm I'm
more in trouble than anything else and
that should never happen the position
might still be playable for black and
and everything but I should not be worse
and of course his move was just bad I
should have checked and played Rook
d8 I was pretty uh stupidly played is he
going Rook E6 now yeah going for the
second second rank
him that was a bad
game whatever it was it was still a
pretty nice Advantage with the double
pawns and I should never be in
trouble absolutely
not can check G5 not sure if that is
leading to mate or any more
trouble simply taking with the Rook is
not bad of
course
not sure maybe we get some two against
one Rook ending the problem here is of
course always that I have less
time
getting a bit away from the pawns there
that that I don't
like not that's not how I wanted to have
things
unfold this is not how you want to play
it
n not
good I can just play this what am I
doing against it a yeah Rook on the
third okay that was not actually a
planned
resource
so I think I'm getting this
Pawn Rook on the
six this this one first
yeah
I got I got no
time I wanted to go on the on the E of
course
but
still nothing going on
really
yeah okay I got a draw in the
end which was a bit more than
deserved I was certainly lost at some
point
not looking too great I'm not not even
leading this
tournament so we
should go for a quick Checkmate here
against
gavan maybe it works this is a good way
to start things if you want to get a
quick M on the
board Queen H 5
coming Knight D5 is a is of course um a
possibility
but not sure queen queen G5 was maybe a
little bit much a normal move like
Bishop H3 was certainly uh just
good but C C5 is
a also a bit
odd
I see the point he wants to blunt my
Bishop
but W this is just crazy F7 this is
attacked not sure if this is any good
it's just a crazy position E2 is hanging
also yeah but there was too much going
on B7 and so on he can take C6 now and
he can take
F7 but F7 I can probably really take
two that's a very strange
position so what's going on now Knight
F6 maybe just let let's develop some
stuff how fatal is Bishop take C6 nobody
knows if I just take now here what's
going on let's take I want to have this
playing and when he cannot recapture
so okay so this
[Music]
one Queen
A4 but I'm not sure I mean my my king
position is not so unsafe this is
hanging
though okay if he takes on
E5 D2 is
hanging my Bishop looks stupid though
okay and know I can
take just happy that this piece is
playing oh didn't see that one
okay I don't I don't think this is
possible I'm just getting too too
much myself here so now um this one
maybe
covering covering um
C6 and I have some some ideas uh on my
own
here maybe there was something better I
don't know it was just it's just a
largely irritating position Knight
G4 where is the maid I don't see a
maid and there should be one
there really should be one now I can
take I
think so go go back and now he's not
threatening anything and I should be
able
to
promote this is a large
threat
yeah that should be end of
game Knight C3 I go Queen
F3 this is also probably right
here
just want to take one moment that I'm
not stumbling into some wacky mate but
there is just
nothing no mate okay yeah I lost the
streak here with this uh draw against uh
P
balma it's getting getting tough here
speaks is also winning all the
games the current game's not clear that
he has here we can see that he's down on
time and an exchange down so maybe he's
um going down should be yeah 7
Seconds that's good ending a streak but
I'd like to get a game on my own of
course okay so let's go one4 for a
change oh that was not what I wanted
anyway what
that's very
weird so let's try to open things
up okay I just want to make sure that
the H file is open
here okay now how do we do this this
one for
oops for Queen
H5 okay so maybe
here I
want if possible to establish
the
the best imaginable control of the light
squares Knight G3 Bishop D3 and just
takes it
okay okay so I can check
now which is definitely not bad let's
say I guess King f8 and then I'm
already very much tempted to
take takes Knight takes there's Knight
E6 and this is just
like this is just this is a lot
already the mate and
knight6 and I mean this is
also coming in fast so check or this one
yeah this looks better get new attackers
into the
game Queen G6 maybe I don't know but
this is
also probably losing some
material yeah I'm
probably
do I do I have more than just winning
material here I don't
know this
one I can always just take G6 and then
win The
Rook I can actually take this this is
stronger it's not stronger actually can
he can take H5 and then he I mean yes
it's winning but it's not stronger than
the other
line you can take H5 Knight takes and
the position is a disaster but the other
one was probably
stronger I'm still a little bit
surprised that he's not just taking on
H5 you should really thank God that he
can trade no he doesn't
okay
um it is a move though
now yeah nothing
else and go
back I mean it's it's very nice but
uh it looked
like maybe there was even more Advantage
somewhere
yeah that was that that's a
pretty that's a a game that can be
costly because it should have been over
really really
fast and um if in the
meantime I'm losing the tournament lead
then
what's the decision here King F7 is the
absolutely only move
check unfortunat I don't see a wind
there it's it's really
annoying it looks fantastic but I don't
see a
win
take
this threatening The Rook
check which he
stopped that wasn't actually a good idea
let's see if I
can that was not a good
idea could have just stayed on the
seventh it's my
idea yeah I'm winning this on time
probably he's just so
slow never speeding up is the thing
never sped
up
H okay I'm still on first place
so okay I've got four minutes left so
the next game depends a little bit on
how the opponent is handling
it but okay I mean speaks can only get
three points so probably it should be
enough mistr maybe if he gets in a win
quickly yeah I need a game first of
all okay
so okay he doesn't want to win the
tournament playing the troll variation
here magnus's troll line
against
ding
it's not really great
but in Blitz chest you can play uh many
things that are not so great and still
kind of
bearable this is one of
them white has a large Advantage here
but the position is still
closed and it's
uh this H5 stuff is really triggering
some
people yeah white doesn't want to fight
for the tournament win it
seems that would have been
uh would need to play much
faster but maybe he just doesn't see an
opportunity given that he's so outr but
I don't know I think you should you
should still
try and he has a large Advantage again
it's
uh my position here is full of
weaknesses
F5 D5 probably
not if he trades now my position could
be could be okay somewhat
okay yeah
still not a fan of my position but okay
now it's getting somewhat
closed it was he should play like C4 and
then D4 yeah that
would ensure that the position would
open n he can still probably play Bishop
G3 Bishop D6 is not
really very
helpful hinting at this and this I tried
to provoke the
capture on
B5 this I like to see that he puts more
stuff on dark
squares
yeah the most likely scenario here is
actually a time win because he's
absolutely
not getting any
quicker like every move takes 10 seconds
and I will get the time lead fairly
fairly soon I'm not sure about the
tournament actually uh yeah probably
Mistral cannot I mean Mistral is my
opponent he he will not catch me because
he will not win this game
but maybe somebody else can overtake us
speaks
maybe doesn't look like it
though if this is absolute real time
then I have won the
tournament okay now um I want to stop D5
he has given me the um the a
file I just
just nice position for The Rook
okay this is a good idea
actually covers B2 very
reliably take
this and now um I
need
one Rook to cover
this
okay yeah's he's defending this quite
well a rook trade would be
great I need
to
this
one hinting at H4 and he's putting more
on dark squares this is good now I need
to play this now this is actually now a
check this is important he cannot take
E6 because D2 Falls with a check and
this is a
problem
yes then he's in some serious
trouble pins all over the
place so I did I did win the thing I can
take
it
all right
so that was loud so I I I won the
tournament that's that's fun and uh it's
okay I played the one draw against PAB
where I was in trouble I was definitely
in trouble in this game um all in all
this is okay just conceding a draw um I
just want to have a look there in this
game
um just one thing I wanted to
check like here because this is this is
a fairly nice one and I'm not playing it
right Queen
D3 I would ideally like to play in a way
that he doesn't get F5 and probably yeah
what the engine is giving here this Rook
F2 something like that put a rook on the
second like this is probably not bad at
first like this and now I should
probably play Rook F2 or so yeah this is
good so that he doesn't have a check
coming
in that means F5 is difficult to play
and then I can start to coordinate this
is always somewhat better the the 0.6 is
a little bit lower than I would expect
um White's advantage to be but it's it's
clear that white is
better Rook D1 yeah I should cover the
second rank yeah the berserking here did
not help Queen D5 is just a
mistake Rook C2 yeah it's the same thing
just stop the counter play on the second
Rank and then continue to do something
and here this is just uh
now leading to a position where black is
is okay I think and a real issue was F6
that that was a move that at first
looked somewhat clever but it's not of
course what I should do is actually I
should take yeah and now it's now it's
clear and here I can play F6
probably
no it's not bad it's not the thing and
the engine just wants to take take C6
yes of course that's possible can simply
or maybe this one first doesn't matter
this and this is really just a Pawn
Yeah Yeah F6 was that was just uh very
superficial
move and now I have to fight for the
draw which is probably not difficult to
get if you have a bit of time the engine
line Rook A1 here looks very convincing
actually and the way I played I was
probably completely lost I just like
here G5 I just with all those quick
moves I just conceded step by step
conceded more
ground like here I'm not so sure that
that could be a
draw I mean not not a force to draw or
something I mean but it it it might be
that you can hold
it that's I don't know it looks again
not good but somewhere here when I got
here this is I think very
drawish yeah that's probably a draw I
would assume if I get the Jeep horn it's
a
draw the way it turned out there was
really nothing going on okay I hope you
enjoyed it and um if you want to get the
Dirty Harry or the C4 Knight F3 course
it's still on for two days or if you
like today and tomorrow so make sure to
to get them thanks for watching